you guys are based in canada
we are that's not good not good
especially with the legislation that
might come down in the next couple years
it it definitely is is not helpful at
this point in time but uh well so there
i mean you've got hate speech laws in
canada right that's right if the
government of canada came to you and
said you are hosting illegal content you
must take it down would you guys take it
down if it was illegal absolutely but
illegal in canada absolutely i'm not
going to jail so this so this means that
like
misgendering i think that's one of the
laws so one one of the things that we uh
that we're doing is that we're
headquartering down in sarasota florida
we announced that a couple months ago
that's a that's a big move that that
we're going to be doing as a company and
uh super excited to to go to florida
better weather too so
i actually would prefer the canadian
weather over florida to be honest really
absolutely yup well if you're a
snowboarder or skier then yeah i can
understand always i can always put on
more clothes i can i can't take all of
it you can never put on enough beanies
that's right sweat sweating is good for
you gets rid of a lot of waste and it is
stuff in your body it is but uh
you know florida's good in january
february i lived there for a year it was
brutal nobody goes outside but in canada
you know you've got some months and
you've got long winters where you just
you know make snowmen but but i i
digress the important question here is
there are a lot of people signing up on
rumble right now you know we're talking
about psychological operations we're
talking about whether companies are
willing to break the law obviously you
know luke is saying you if it's if it's
legal content it should be allowed but
where you're at right now in canada
i mean
have you been forced to ban anybody on
hate speech or anything like that by the
government or any
no institutions come to us uh with
respect to that
but
i can tell you that
you know where
the legislation that is going to come
that's that i think is even more
concerning is uh bill c-10 in canada
where the they want to have the
government actually regulate what kind
of content you are displaying and uh
through the crtc and think about that
they're going to control what you see
now
um and whatever that may look like
it's in full progress if that passes and
then there's other legislation that's
being proposed now
um we haven't seen it but that could
happen in the next year as this uh the
trudeau government is continuing so
you know
the best thing for for rumble is just at
this point is to is to be prepared for
that situation and you know we'll we'll
be in florida and by this year so if i
could just ask you on a follow-up
question
if you're in canada right now the
canadian government says take this
content down you will but if you move
down to florida right and you
incorporate there and the canadian
government says i want you to hide this
video from our viewers will you get rid
of those videos when you're not in their
jurisdiction so jurisdictional issues is
a whole different thing because you have
the uk that has one set of laws you have
canada that has another set of laws you
have the us that has their set of laws
and we have to find a way to to meet the
laws of of every country and this this
gets so complicated when you think about
it like as a startup imagine a startup
having to like
have lawyers help you in every single
jurisdiction and fall it makes it so
difficult the barrier of entry just to
enter this market is is so difficult to
be to be like youtube into competing
against youtube you need like
significant financing significant legal
help signifies a lot to navigate it's so
complicated um and it makes it so hard
but we're lucky that we're in a really
good place right now where we have we
have a pretty good team and uh we're
gonna we're gonna follow each
jurisdiction the way the way it needs to
be done so if canada says get rid of
this video and you're in florida you
will
it like i have to look at the situation
and the scenario i can't you know
say someone misgendered someone on on a
rumble video the canadian government
says we want you to take that down
you're in florida what do you do so at
this point i i don't have an answer for
that because we haven't we haven't come
up with that
that policy we haven't looked at that um
and one of the things that uh we want to
do as we're growing like i said we've
had a policy since 2013 it's been
virtually the same in spirit um all the
way through the key for us is to never
move the goal posts like these other
companies every two weeks you're seeing
them change but we're also not
good enough because in 2013 it was one
it was one world and in 2000 and i guess
22 now it's a whole different world so
what we want to do is uh you know after
i did the the podcast with uh viva viva
fray and and robert barnes you know we
had some chats after that we we want to
bring the community in we want to bring
guys like robert barnes and viva frey to
help us develop this in a way that stays
in the spirit of free speech as much as
possible and really be able to handle
these jurisdictional issues that are
that are there these app store issues
that are there there we want to do it in
a way that
it's almost better if the community
helps us develop this than you know one
single authority like myself saying this
is how we're going to do it and this is
the best way so what an app store we're
really we're
we're we're in talks to do that with
viva and robert barnes and uh
we you know i i want to bring in as many
people i want to you know seek your
advice too like how do you handle app
store issues and policy in terms of
conditions like these are such
tricky things
it's a cabal i mean let's be real the
this silicon valley operates like a
cabal when minds gets one tiny
infraction that's negligible they'll be
like we're going to knock you off the
app store whereas twitter just does
whatever they want i think i don't know
if that that that's
particularly poor is that public that
story yeah yeah porn mines was often on
the the app store with dealing with porn
issues whereas twitter just had porn the
whole time allows it that's unbelievable
when you look at the double standard and
and that's that's totally unfair how are
we supposed to compete as a company if
minds can't
you know get the same rule set that
twitter's getting facebook first thing
you do is acknowledge it which we just
did and then you got to start building a
system where that is not part of the
system which is like a decentralized uh
open free software meta-net i i agree
and you know decentralization is a huge
key but i think even before that right
now and this is one of the things that
we're really focused on is we got to
build we got to build infrastructure
because you can't turn anything on
without the infrastructure you saw what
happened to parlor they got turned off
overnight and then once you have the
infrastructure in place uh you know
common carrier-based infrastructure then
you can start building things and you
can you know you can really kind of take
all kinds of different businesses and
really build off of that if you want
people to help you build and if you want
to build a community you got to build a
lot of trust
so you know there's a big question you
guys got a lot of institutional money
that usually corrupts companies what
plan do you have to show that you won't
be corrupted and what can you offer the
people who are coming to you as as
transparency and oversight that you will
treat them differently than youtube did
yeah no this is a that's a great
question um
so one of the things that we did when we
decided to to merge with uh with cfei is
we went out and raised money on the
premise that we're going to be immune to
cancel culture
we're we're going to be restoring the
internet to its roots by making it free
and open again building a cloud that's
going to be as close to a common carrier
as possible a rumble platform that is
not going to censor that's what we told
investors that's what we raised money on
that's what we're doing that's what we
went to cantor fitzgerald for
and
we now if we will be one of the first
companies to to enter the public markets
once this merge concludes
on the on that premise we're not on the
we're not going into the into the public
markets on the premise of a google that
requires you know
all these other things we're on the
premise that we're going to be immune to
cancel culture and if we don't live up
to that then we now have a massive
liability on our hands we have no choice
but to stick we put the stake in the
ground on that premise
twitter was the free speech wing of the
free speech party
yeah
we need we need
initially when they got started they
joked that they were the free speech
wing of the free speech party so they
made all the same statements and
promises youtube used to allow
uh the craziest videos pranks involving
violence
and so i think it's really easy for you
to say like here's our mission statement
when you're growing and competing but
what happens when you reach that that
plateau where you're now on a similar
level and all of a sudden you've got
investors you've got government
interests you've got you know you've got
congress breathing down your neck all of
a sudden you're like it is easier just
to get rid of this and not fight
yeah in in certain cases you might think
that um it all depends on the person
that's that's there um can you make
corporate bylaws
barring something i don't know that's a
good question i i don't know the answer
to that can we uh maybe make a pledge
towards transparency oversight well one
thing we did do um and i think this is
unprecedented is that
when after we announced the the merge
with cfei
um we we had a company ask us to
demonetize uh dan bongino
and instead of complying with doing that
gave him a raise
yes we did
we cloned it finally released the damn
the clones you respond to that we're
giving them some percent what what we
did is we canceled tremor um unruly in
tremor media
they they
said we
you know they cited that they saw
content that they didn't like and we
asked them where's that content that
they don't like does that violate our
terms of service
no response and and we said we said
basically if you don't provide us the
information that that uh that violates
our term of service we will
we're effectively canceling if you want
to appeal with us to get to bring ads
back on rumble uh you let us know by
this date
so there's an advertising and we we
canceled we canceled one of the largest
uh advertising networks on the planet um
because they tried to cancel dan bongino
well that's canceled culture now you're
not just kidding
are you aware of the esg score
not not particularly i think that's
that's with respect to environmental so
this is the environmental social and
corporate government score that a lot of
bigger financial institutions like
blackstone use as a way of funneling
money into
of course big companies so to comply
with that you have to push a certain
narrative have certain beliefs have uh
certain amounts of people based on their
identities and their race and there's
there's many different things but but
they essentially the big money guys come
and say you guys got to play by these
rules you guys have a good score you
comply with our agenda you get more
money you get more loans what's
preventing you guys from being affected
by the esg score
well
and blackstone like if blackstone came
and said we'll give you a bunch of money
would you accept it
well they they i guess can't they just
publicly go and buy the the public
shares on the market isn't that how it
works they they have the option to do
that they know what we're all about if
they if they're supportive of our
mission and what we're doing and the
creators on our platform go ahead but
like at the same time
you know
we're we're not gonna i'm we're not
gonna bend our mission i'm not gonna
bend this mission i have roughly 85
voting control and i'm not going to bend
for changing this mission where the
mission is to restore the routes
to go to create that free and open
internet we once had what will happen is
uh blackstone like state street a big
investment firms will collude to get
like 20 percent of the company they
can't there's only eleven percent
roughly eleven available eleven percent
is available from and then yeah canters
are roughly two to three it's all public
this information you're only selling
eleven percent of the company i'll i'll
have about eighty-five voting control
it's all public on on the site you can
kind of see the breakdown of the of the
current holders versus uh our current
holders are
a large portion of this i think how big
is your board
so i'm putting that together right now
um that's i'm working really hard is
that public even are you excited
it will become public that that
information that i would imagine that
these companies will try to get somebody
on your board and then that once they're
on the board they start to see
discontent with other board members when
you're not around and that's how they'll
try and get you out but i'll have what
they did to doors
i have 85 percent control the voting
shareholder voting control so that that
allows me to i i think the rules
i don't want to speak out of line um but
i i think the 85
allows a lot like you could just kick
somebody off the board
i don't yeah it's i don't know hopefully
i i don't know about canadian law but
this will be this will be u.s this will
be us in the united states you still
have to convene a meeting the meeting
has to be there's process there's you
have to abide by process and you have to
do everything by the book and uh but
when you have 85 percent uh voting
control to appoint boards of the the
directors uh that's a significant
controlling interest in the company
and uh it allows uh it it really really
allows us to protect that mission but i
also think that the bigger protection is
not just me having that that control
it's really drawing a stake in the sand
of what this company is our shareholder
base whoever is going to be buying
rumble is uh
it really believes in what we're doing i
i don't even i i'm not sure if if
institutions
will institutions be interested they
should be because it's going to i think
this is the future of the world i i
think free freedom is you you can't buy
that that's something that you know we
need in this point on this planet more
than anything are you gonna are you ever
going to sell your stock um and and if
you do how much stock would you sell and
that's another question
how should i answer that one
um no so like
at this point
you know i'm all in and it what i'm
seeing on the
what i'm seeing on the internet and what
i'm seeing how this internet has changed
in the last 15 years um really
really it's really more of a mission now
than anything else
in the world and i feel like we're
we're the tip of the spear of really
protecting the free and the open
internet especially if we really build
this infrastructure out and uh you know
we get
we really support a lot of businesses i
i think that that's going to be a really
important a really important factor in
in the next couple years and i really
need to go all in on this this is not
about selling out and going out yeah the
networking thing is huge if we can
somehow build a meshed network maybe
with devices like the freedom phone or
sort of phone where people we can host
our servers
i think you might be the guy to to leak
because i know your history in building
servers
and your interest in building up the
network
i don't know
i'm sorry okay that's good i don't know
if i have uh enough faith in people you
know if uh
be it you or getter i think that for the
most part whether people want to
acknowledge it or not they're kind of
they're moving only in the direction
they can they can move in
so for a rumble for getter for even
minds
there's an opportunity in that youtube
is killing conversations you know
they they make it impossible to have
meaningful conversations it is harder
and harder every day and it's
fascinating when i see how many channels
will get a guideline strike over similar
conversations we'd have but obviously
we're a big show youtube's probably
scared because that's that's the way the
game is played that's the way the
machine works youtube can only do what
the culture will tolerate so what i mean
by that is
i fully believe like with what i saw at
vice there will come a point where
unless you put in legal
bylaws or restrictions
or or something i don't even know if
that would work to be honest
there it's only a matter of time before
rumble becomes youtube in the exact same
way but that doesn't mean right now what
you're doing is bad it means
there's always going to be a new market
opportunity for someone to bring back
real real and raw conversations thanks
for checking out this segment from the
tim cast irl podcast if you want to
watch live you can check out this
channel monday through friday at 8pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you